- I have to talk about Housewives.
So I heard that you and Erica
had like a little thing,
but y'all are good now?
- Well, you know she was upset...
- Okay when you start with "well."
- I know, exactly.
No, we actually are good.
We are good right now.
There were things in the show
that she saw over the season,
obviously, that hurt
her feelings, you know?
And, you know, we had a lot of questions.
It was very confusing.
And then there was a scene where
my husband and PK were like,
kind of like laughing and then, PK,
they make me laugh and it's hard.
It's like, when you're,
when you're in church or something,
you're not supposed to
laugh and then you know,
you can't help it.
- Yeah, I laugh in inappropriate
times all the time.
- Right, and so that was kind of a thing.
And I knew, oh gosh,
when she sees this,
she's going to be upset.
And so, but we, you know,
we work through things on the reunion.
- That's hard, like with, yeah,
friendships in general are hard...
- You think filming
Halloween was hard and scary?
Deal with these women for a bit.